foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bone end of
the week we have a great bonehead of the
week for you today this week on Friday
every single Friday in the second hour
of the Tony Michaels podcast every
single Friday and we also we also if
you're over on the Midas Dutch Network
we broadcast we replay the broadcast on
a minor statue Network so don't forget
to follow us over the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube even though we've had
a little bit of YouTube treble here
lately we're back we're bad baby boys we
are some bad boys back baby we just came
out of jail yeah that's true what's up
that's right we're we're YouTube
criminals and we were locked up for
quite some time lock us up on YouTube
game we got we had some bonus here
um boy
boy are they boneheaded um and this was
a close race I actually thought one of
these was gonna come out front but it
was I gotta tell you when I made the
graphic today for the video I was like
damn this is actually way closer than I
thought it was gonna be Ryan I I really
thought um I really thought one of them
would make their way out front and and
not stop but yeah um
a group of boneheads ooh some [ __ ]
bonus so where should we start should we
start with a judge yeah I think I think
we should start with let's judge judge
judgment yeah judge why I mean if she if
you can consider her a [ __ ] judge
well yeah yeah I mean let's what I find
funny about the situation is that at the
end of the day the people that were also
very critical of her were Trump
appointed judges
wait wait now you're the criticism that
you're speaking of where did the
criticism appear right so this was if we
go back to where this started right
Trump was like Hey I want to shop this
around to different judges and I'm sure
I am sure he had a list of people to be
like look this is who we brought in we
think we might have a good choice it's
like when people are trying to like when
lawyers are trying to select a journey
like who are they more willing to feel
like sympathetic or be more kind of
objective and judgmental about the the
person that's on on trial so with this
I'm sure they had a list of people and
they're like look we we brought her in
so she kind of owes us a favor I feel
like she'll do us a solid
and they went to her and they said hey
we should actually have these documents
we want you to choose a special Master
for us after you know after Trump had
whined and cried about having this one
in a special Master the deal was like
fine well [ __ ] it whatever okay
she gets uh on the case and she says
actually you you the doj don't have
rights to these documents it's actually
Trump's property it's kind of weird kind
of weird yeah it doesn't make any sense
in that it does make Trump sense you
know right but I mean it makes sense in
the in the fact that the only way for
him to really skate criminal charges
here is if he can somehow prove that
these are his not the government right
exactly so she puts out her her legal
opinion and says yeah these documents
these especially these hundred
classified documents the doj should not
actually be able to review any further
and uh it should be you know the
basically ruling in favor of trump
which a lot of people at the time were
like you know what the [ __ ] is going on
and if this gets uh appealed then or if
they try to appeal it it's going to go
in the doj's favor because this is not
how someone should rule
so at that point everyone is talking uh
there is obviously criticism the
criticism that follows especially in the
way that how judge Eileen Cannon uh went
through this was from Trump appointed
judges
which is even which which again like I
said makes us even more beautiful
because it's almost it's almost as good
as the judges that were Trump appointed
that overruled to say or like you know
kind of throughout the election fraud
cases that Giuliani and others brought
forward because they're like oh they
thought they were going to be able you
know no problem go through and say there
was election fraud and those judges were
going to take it but it turns out that
those judges were like ah you know what
look I'm willing to support you only so
far but this [ __ ] [ __ ] is crazy and I
can't do it
and so it's the same situation where
they've appointed these judges because
loyalty and they want them to you know
do what they want they want to be a
follower and then it turns out these
judges actually [ __ ] turn around and
say that's not how the law works right
well and even even this uh the Deary the
special master that was appointed
because Dairy is a federal judge which
it's kind of awkward to have a sp
apparently to have a special master who
is a sitting federal judge that doesn't
happen a lot but the reason why it
happened in this situation is because I
believe the Trump team thought that this
guy was corrupt because he was part of
the fisa court that that issued the
warrant for the wiretaps on Carter page
so like oh this guy is totally
corruptable which if you go back and
look at the Carter page fisa warrant
there wasn't corruption yeah in that it
was a mistake but it wasn't corruption
on the fisa courts part right so I don't
understand if that was their logic that
this judge Deary was somehow corruptible
cool but it almost feels like because in
their little where they were nominating
a recommending special Masters they had
one other but this one was Trump's
appointment they wanted Deary but they
had two choices and they made him one of
the choices but they called him a
retired and one that retired in so many
words but they almost thought that he
was retired he wasn't sitting on a
current federal bench right so it's
almost they thought like okay he's
corruptable and he's retired so he won't
be he won't be tied to any kind of you
know out their commitment to the current
court or something I don't know but he's
in the he's in the eastern district
of New York right he's a sitting judge a
sitting federal judge and it is it's not
unheard of but it is kind of weird that
a sitting federal judge is a special
Master but they have special legal
things where they can do that and so
they did it because the doj's like oh
you want Deary oh you [ __ ] up because
doj's like this guy is a no-nonsense
judge yeah he follows he literally he's
not he was nominated under Ronald Reagan
yeah he was confirmed under Ronald
Reagan this guy's not just been on the
court for a couple years motherfucker's
been on the court for a long damn time
knows how it works right he's been a
federal judge for quite some time yeah
and he's always been No Nonsense if you
look at this guy's record he's not
really a partisan and and what I mean by
that is he's not really a liberal he's
not a conservative he's just like he's
as benign as uh federal judges you might
want right right like in all rule of law
fairness he's really been right and why
they selected this guy is beyond me
because immediately when he gets to be
the special Master the first question he
asked is the question that this [ __ ]
bonehead Cannon should have asked right
and he totally [ __ ] her you know I
don't know if she's gonna show up on the
Apple guy but she totally got cocked
here and the reason why is because he
says hey you're claiming As Trump and
his legal team you're claiming that you
Declassified these documents right I
want to see the proof where you declare
which it doesn't matter and he knows it
doesn't matter but he knows that that
one question alone
totally smashes up their entire [ __ ]
argument over this whole thing because
they keep saying I Declassified them as
if that exalts them of any crime of
taking the [ __ ] stealing the documents
harboring them not securing them and
obstructing justice to get them back
like not the D the classification of
these documents regardless of what you
think actually happens or how it gets
Declassified it doesn't make a
difference one iota and that's what the
judge Deary understands and he's like
hey your main argument here is [ __ ]
I get that but I want to see proof that
you even can make this argument because
they actually have to have evidence to
make the argument
and I was gonna say that he he really
did come forward and was like look step
up or shut up right that was the way
that they looked because it was like
look you claim that you Declassified
these documents fine okay whatever
if you did so show me the proof which is
the same thing that everyone has said
which is like okay look you claim to
have waved your hands and thought it or
whatever that you declassify these
things but we need some sort of receipts
a piece of paper some other agency that
approved it something to show us that
you actually Declassified not some
[ __ ] cash Patel interview on Fox News
well but that's the thing but that's the
thing is they they walked they moved the
goal post like they always do because
cash Patel came out and he said I was
standing in the room when he did it and
now yesterday or well the day before
yesterday he goes on Sean handed it and
he that's not what he says at all he
doesn't say I stood over the boxes and
declared them Declassified he says well
I thought it so that must Beth what it
is if right exactly literally they are
even moving the goal post because here's
the thing folks they know they're [ __ ]
there is no evidence cash Patel when he
tells you that [ __ ] on some interview
somewhere and you notice cash Patel
hasn't been in the news here lately nope
because he's completely I'm sure he uh
he might have gotten I don't know like a
subpoena or something right from the doj
to be like hey so you said this stuff
yeah yeah talk a little bit so you were
there when he was doing this
it's kind of funny how you would say out
in public that you were there when he
was committing crime really funny how
cash Patel would do that the other thing
too here that I think people are missing
from the the interview that I think
Canon [ __ ] totally dropped the ball
on is what the documents are what they
are folks I'm just I'm just speculating
here and I'm only using the Cheeto dust
Mobsters projection to to
um to actually do the speculation but
it's pretty easy to read him he's
predictably unpredictable my guess is
almost every single document that he
stole that has especially human assets
on it
um it is intelligence that was collected
on him it has his name on the documents
its intelligence that was elected by our
intelligence to see about him we know
that there was Intelligence collected on
we know he colluded we know he tried to
obstruct an investigation in the Russian
collusion and our government on the 2016
election we know that we know they
invited Russians to the Trump Tower we
know all of this and I would almost bet
of my last dollar is that those
documents most of the documents he
stoled are Intelligence on himself yeah
because he's not interested in anything
else but himself anyway so why would he
makes his name and he's like that mine
mine mine well and that's the other
reason why he thinks it's his right
don't you think well I think 100 I think
the other thing too is like if my hands
are on it it's mine which is like that's
not how that works also like again there
is a process and when when he goes on
Sean Hannity and his [ __ ] fake gold
room and says I thought it therefore it
is and he says oh well actually there's
no real process to it that is not at all
true there is is a process you can as a
I mean a president can unilaterally
declassify things but there's a process
that goes in where the agency that
classify them says hey yes we can
declassify it there is a process you
have to get the people involved who who
made the choices they actually the
public cannot know this right now well
and and to be fair a president can
actually override that but again it's
not just the thought in your brain right
there would be some sort of back and
forth It's called government I don't
know it's called crazy I don't know
crazy it's kind of weird but it's one of
those weird things that yeah I know it's
one of those things again that's like if
you in fact did it then you should have
no problem no problem whatsoever to
prove that you did it you've got an
email you've got a letter you got a
phone call you got a video you got a
voice recording you have something
something besides your dumb ass fat
orange [ __ ] brain right it's not that
because that's not a real thing so
either you did it and you've got
evidence for it or you didn't do it and
you're trying to make up and lie about
you did do it right well I'm sure we're
going to get into more of this and I
want to give you my opinion on what they
would do if Jill Biden said this type of
[ __ ] so remind me when we get to this
this other bonehead yeah yeah because I
know we're going to talk about that but
let's talk about Ron Ron DeSantis Rhonda
Santos go [ __ ] himself you know what I
mean Ron human trafficking to Santas
oh this guy and I know I know this kind
of sinks into you uh really deep Gabe
because your family came here
um from Mexico to seek a better life in
America and your dad worked his ass off
to do that and you're here as an
American citizen because of that yeah um
and for them to treat these human beings
like just pieces of meat I know makes
you infuriated yeah um it is because
it's personal to you yeah I mean like I
know how hard my dad worked and how much
that he sacrificed to provide for our
family and how much that he wanted us my
brother and myself to have a better life
and so when I see someone like Ron
DeSantis or Greg Abbott just goes
willy-nilly oh yeah well you know I
throw him on a plane I shoot him up to
Martha's Vineyard or I shoot him over to
you know uh
VP Harris's house or shoot him up to
Delaware to go see you know President
Biden that type of stuff where it's like
they aren't they aren't humans they're
not treated like humans they're treated
like objects and it's disgusting
because they give no actual uh care as a
fellow human would toward another human
they don't actually follow the Christian
values they don't actually say hey look
maybe we should treat these people that
are seeking Asylum and refuge and a
better life in this country an
opportunity instead of lying to them
giving them some BS pamphlet lying about
this Perla which I'm sure is Christina
Pusha which is kind of the right-hand
person the director of of Ron DeSantis
and that also seems like the the the the
this target for the pro the criminal
probe that's happening and so like it's
not just them and so right now I'm I'm
happy to see that like not only is our
investigation from Javier Salazar in San
Antonio of Bexar County not only are we
seeing a class action lawsuit from the
48 migrants that were flown under false
pretenses to Martha's Vineyard but we're
now seeing this moment of like there are
consequences for the actions that you
take there are consequences for you
being a shitty awful garbage human being
and not respecting someone else who is
trying to seek the thing that you
promise that is something that you get
in this country which is you get the
family you get the house you get this
you get that but if someone doesn't look
white you know they're brown they're
black whatever they are you don't get
the same rights you don't get the same
opportunities you don't get the same
amount of respect and freedom and
liberty that we've declared in the
Constitution that you [ __ ] rile
yourselves up as [ __ ] Patriots but
really you're all just a bunch of
[ __ ] fake treats you're not real you
don't actually care about people you are
hypocrites you don't follow the
Constitution you don't respect Law and
Order despite that you say oh we're the
party Law and Order you don't actually
care for the the to back the blue like
we saw that on January 6th like this is
a party that is anti-American it is
anti-life it is just anti-human rights
and at the end of the day that is what
the Republican party is so when you see
Ron DeSantis ship someone over from
Texas
on a plane to Martha's Vineyard because
ah you know what we're gonna [ __ ] own
the libs that is a terrible thing to do
that is a terrible human and as a
terrible party that stands behind him
and supports like [ __ ] Ted Cruz and
these other [ __ ] cups well because
today is there a commitment to Cruelty
and their commitment is to do more of
this stuff and and to treat other human
beings like pieces of meat analytical
political ponds because let me tell you
something most areas in this country
blue States especially and a lot of
these big metropolitan areas would
welcome these migrants these refugees
who are seeking as I am to come here
they would love for them if if they
could find a way for Greg Abbott and Ron
DeSantis to organize to spend the
federal dollars that they've given and
to make it efficient to get them to
their areas the problem is the reason
why they had to go down to Texas and San
Antonio to coerce these people out of
shelters is because they are seeking
asylum in Texas yeah there's and they
have a federal courthouse there where
they have to appear for their legal
Asylum hearing right and they can't go
to [ __ ] other states they can't go to
other places yet because they have to
get their Asylum done so that they can
actually move right and what these
Republicans these vile cruel pieces of
[ __ ] are doing is coercing these people
out of a situation where they're seeking
legal asylum in this country for for
Refuge to America for the American dream
the American the Liberty that they claim
to love which they only love it for
white Christian Nationals and that's it
um and really honestly if you have the
passion that Gabe has for Ron DeSantis
going and [ __ ] himself show it with
the T-shirt Ronda Santos can go [ __ ]
so the other the other thing I want to
point out is the fact that like even if
you say you know we've got an
immigration problem and we need to fix
it great fine that's totally a thing
let's actually bring it out to the table
but if you're willing to lie uh you know
uh Hoodwink uh you know bait and switch
which someone and say oh you know again
who are seeking Asylum and have have
actual Court appearances in Texas and
then say get on this flight we'll give
you money we'll give you shelter we'll
take you to this place
nice
miles away thousands of miles away right
from from somewhere that not only are
you thousands of miles or hundreds of
miles from your where your actual home
original home was in these countries
that you were seeking Asylum from so now
you're in a new country and then you say
oh actually we're going to ship you off
to this spot again to own the lips like
it's really crazy the biggest thing the
biggest [ __ ] problem that I have with
this is the fact that innocent innocent
Floridians and Texans they are paying
the price literally right the price
their tax dollars are going in and
paying for the transportation the
illegal transportation of these migrants
who are seeking Asylum as a political
stunt for a campaign right so you've got
some you've got a you've got a governor
in Texas or and you've got a governor in
Florida and they're both trying to see
who can do the worst here like the fact
that you're trying to outdo the other
one to see hey how much shittier can I
be than you
is it well I mean I mean that's trumpism
in in I mean in a nutshell well you're
100 I mean the Cheeto dust mobster is
went all full q and on over on fraud
social apparently but I guess people are
totally fine with with paying extra
money or having their tax dollars they
could go towards roads infrastructure uh
repairing your community actually going
to the things that you say hey I'm
paying my taxes they should go to the
things that I have
actually a stake in do not say oh you
should take that money and then go pay
for these people to be illegally
transported across state lines did I
mess up here did I get the winner wrong
I think I got the winner wrong here
do I have the wrong winner in there no I
don't know did you do the math because
I'm on the winner right now
I did not know that he won I thought the
other guy won the former guy oh uh yes
he he did did he inch he inched out he
inched out yeah this is my mistake oh my
god this is my mistake folks this is my
mistake folks I thought I really thought
that the Cheeto dust mobster I really
thought that he won but I see I'm giving
it away I'm giving it away wow and it
was Ron DeSantis
we'll come back around we'll come back
we got enough uh Rhonda santis can go
[ __ ] himself energy yeah for the winner
and again if you want to get some Rhonda
Santos can go [ __ ] himself merch go to
store.dtonymichaels.com it's a great
design we made the meme and everyone's
like t-shirts so I made a t-shirt so
there's hoodies coffee cups cut I'm
seeing a lot of suggestions for fake
Gabe to be nominated as like Alpha cook
or dishonorable mention oh really look
if fake Gabe wants to submit his real
photo yeah absolutely yeah [ __ ] the
other Avatar then I'll take it and I I
will consider you make the concern of
that type well let's let's move on to uh
then the former guy here I want to I
want to get to this because we're we're
gonna run out of time here
um
as I was saying before I want to mention
this whole I thinketh and they be
Declassified if this whatever this is
this if the president thinks it then
it's a thing here's the thing can you
[ __ ] imagine Gabe if today Joe
Biden's like I'm calling a press
conference and he comes out in front of
the microphone and he says on January
20th 2021 when my hand left the Bible
yeah and I was president at that moment
in time I'm telling you right now
retroactively that at that moment I
thought in my brain
that all all the records yeah that were
Declassified by Donald Trump are
reclassified the way they were before
that means he goes to jail no get out of
jail free card go lock him up get the
[ __ ] handcuffs arrest him and oh by
the way get Donald Trump Jr's laptop and
get Eric Eric Trump's uh diary get it
all get it all from them lock them up
lock them up lock them up can you
[ __ ] imagine oh D just the
hemorrhaging on the right they would
lose their [ __ ] minds because it's
not a thing it's it Joe Biden couldn't
come out and say that nonsense right
because it isn't real that's why it's
really frustrating when a bunch of
[ __ ] dummies in this country a bunch
of boneheads these Q Anon cult members
believe this nonsense when this orange
Mussolini Jesus says it what the [ __ ]
are you talking about it's like you know
they're this whole like ID classified
everything
oh you know
that type of logic
doesn't really work when you can't tell
me what the [ __ ] you have in those boxes
right like if you just took a [ __ ] ton
of [ __ ] because it mentioned your name
or it was this classified nuclear
documents or this or that or whatever
right
if you just took and were like yep
everything in these boxes Declassified
doesn't work that way because you have
to show me and prove that you knew what
you took should have been Declassified
just like if Joe Biden were to say I
classified everything it'd be like well
maybe some of those things were really
Declassified but now your reclass but
like there's no list there's no order
there's no actual function it's all
chaos and this guy is just believing for
whatever insane reason that if he thinks
it
then it becomes reality it's really you
know what if you really thought hard
enough that maybe he would have won the
election I don't know but turns out that
another seven plus million people said
not your thought is pretty [ __ ] so
goodbye right and we don't want a
fascist running our country here's
here's the clip from Hannity it's a
longer clip but there's several things
in this that I want to talk about so
let's watch this clip here because he
says he says a couple of things Gabe
number one he says at Mar-A-Lago and
wherever which means there's other
documents wherever he has other
properties or right other presences or
it has a presence somewhere right and
then he talks about Russia and then he
talks about Russia Russia Russia rush
Russia which and information on him and
the Clinton emails this only tells me
that he's projecting that all the
intelligence that he was trying to
gather up was Intelligence that the
intelligence agency collected on him and
you know which kind of brings up a point
remember when he was saying oh I was
taking this for my library you remember
that my presidential life remember that
was one of their flimsy arguments that
they moved the goal post on yeah he was
taking it so it didn't end up in front
of the American people 50 60 years from
now and they know yeah this guy holy
[ __ ] this guy was a Trader before 2016.
yeah
this guy was a he's been a traitor for a
long time I can't believe Americans
actually supported this Mussolini
Mussolini orange Jesus I cannot believe
it and that's what he's trying that's
why he wants to hide it
this is a great uh steal uh he was
jacked y'all the whole time because he
was really pissed off he's trying to
prevent himself from
[Laughter]
wait wait wait did it
[Music]
that's that's it
I mean again can you can you grab that
can you grab the picture of his new
diaper
while we're talking go ahead what were
you gonna say sorry no I was just gonna
say I actually was going to point out oh
okay the the uh dumpy lump that he left
in his back from I guess hey in his junk
in his trunk yeah like ooh trumpy got
back
okay well we were thinking the same
thing let's let's uh let's watch this
clip of Dumb and Dumber talk about how
it doesn't work so let me ask you this
question because I I think this is the
next logical question because the
president of the United States you
unlike say Hillary Clinton in her case a
president has the power to declassify
correct okay you had said on Truth
social a number of times you did
declasses oh yeah okay I do is there a
process what was your process to be it
doesn't have to be a process as I
understand it you know there's different
people say different things but as I
understand there doesn't have to be if
you're the president of the United
States you can declassify just by saying
it's Declassified even by thinking about
it this is really embarrassing this is
so embarrassing I can't even believe
that these people are like this is my
guy like just in this little this first
30 seconds of this interview it's it's
so stupid it's so dumb and they're like
they're even trying to almost figure out
a way to convince even the dumbest of
the dumb that hey it really is just a
situation where he's so powerful and
he's so you know he's such a great
leader that he can just think it that
other leaders can't do that it's just
him that can do that like this is the
same type of stuff as when they think oh
Joe Biden is the one controlling
inflation and gas prices and this and
that like it's the same type of logic
it's so [ __ ] asinine it doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense so when you've got
this guy saying oh well yeah there's no
real process as far as I know I just
classic there is a process and I would
hope that if someone's going to lie
about stealing classified documents from
the government and playing this whole
like uh I don't have it I have it I
don't really have it here are some
documents but they're not all the
documents and then oh you guys came into
my house illegally to get the documents
that I told you I didn't have
at the end of the day if you're gonna
lie about this stuff if you're gonna if
you're gonna say oh I actually did
declassify them you better [ __ ] know
the actual process that's involved you
better know like oh well actually this
actually is Declassified or it's a
little bit different in this case
because of XYZ but if you just say yeah
there's actually no process to it I can
declassify whatever I want and if I
think it then everyone else should
[ __ ] know that it's Declassified
again I would hope that if someone's
going to steal these documents and try
to make this argument that they would at
least know some nuances of the actual
process to try to navigate it out other
than I thought it so it's a thing
so Elgin Charles has it here you sent it
he said
did Donald Trump get a BBL for anyone
who doesn't know what a BBL is I believe
it's a Brazilian butt lift is that what
the is that what a BBL is yeah that's
the one that I've seen where they take
fat out of the another part of your body
and and inject it into your ass is that
the I mean that's the that's the actual
person I mean you know not so I'm not so
you know crude as I put it but you know
what damn it could be like oh it's be
back later but uh it's it is Brazilian
butt lift right BBL is Brazilian I've
seen I've seen uh some some bad like
online someone's like don't get a
Brazilian butt lift you know like or
like here's the results and they were
holding yeah so does it does it depend
on your plastic surgeon I would imagine
it's kind of like a mechanic like if you
go get your your engine replaced right
if you have a really shitty mechanic it
may not turn out so great but if you
have a good mechanic you may be able to
do this he or she may be able to do the
job and get the engine done yeah you
know you're paying for quality and
hoping that the mechanic that's doing
the work on your car is actually uh
smart competent yeah yeah competent
actually knows what they're talking
about but yeah it is uh it this one
looks like a really if this is a BBL if
elgin's right here and he did get a BBL
this is his plastic surgeon was way off
the Mark
um because Elgin also yeah well Elgin
also says I guess he's preparing
for his time in the clink I don't I
don't know if this is like Elgin I don't
know this is a reference like people are
gonna like this or what but he even
gives an arrow here dude's got a fat ass
anyways yeah my dude's got a fat ass if
you ever seen pictures of him golfing or
or tennis he's got a fat I mean yeah
he's got he's got Big Macs as far as the
eye can see with you know
maybe crazy could be crazy thought here
maybe he's got documents stuffed in his
ass oh maybe you're always walking with
these dogs because he doesn't want him
to search anywhere else that's maybe
where the whatever is he's like
whatever like in my diaper right exactly
like the idea that the idea he's like
yeah or whatever like I don't know it
could be like wherever uh and you know
meanwhile like documents are probably I
made a joke about how he you know maybe
he had a stuff in his jacket but then I
really looked at the video later and I
was like could be maybe he's got [ __ ]
stuffed in his pants like I don't know
actual [ __ ] but he's got [ __ ] stuffed in
his pants that are actual documents this
seems to be growing look at that it's
very it's protective
God damn road there I know I well and
you know it's I I stopped carrying my
wallet my back pocket because you'd
always do the you know you didn't sit on
a bet it's bad for your hip right right
fine but so maybe at first you think
this but you're like no that wallet
would be the size of an Oldsmobile to
get your ass to go up like that I mean
it was it was when I when I see this I
immediately go to the right Kindergarten
Cop with Arnold Schwarzenegger right and
he's like oh I've got my you know I got
a headache right and the kid's like well
maybe it's a tumor and he's like it's
not a tumor and that is what I imagine
here it's not a BBL like you've got this
junk and you got this dump truck
full of documents and and trying here is
like oh what's going on with your back
maybe uh he's like I don't know maybe
it's a tumor he's like it's not a tumor
it's not a tumor it's not a tumor it's
like an Arnold Schwarzenegger uh Donald
Trump there uh but the idea that he's
got this [ __ ] fat ass right thick
with three K's
uh that is it looks like it looks like
the uh uh Gabe we got some breaking news
here on bone end of the week because we
got an alpha cook I don't mean to switch
gear so fast yeah yeah but it looks like
people are doing this um they're having
a press conference here who would
explain to the Bone ended or the alpha
cuck is or the weak there's Jr gay go
ahead J.R Majewski yeah some people
might know him as the man I sent you a
couple links for photos he made his his
self known by creating a huge Trump
Banner on his lawn he painted his whole
lawn as a trump flag right and it was
all over social media it was all all
over right it was a really shitty paint
job too I made fun of it on an old
sketch I did I think we talked about it
a couple times on the show because he
was an insurrectionist too right exactly
so not only is he in insurrectionist he
was there at the Capitol storming he
also is a q Anon believer he believes
that January 6 was actually FBI go
figure uh and now he's running for uh
Ohio's uh Congressional Ninth District
is this the guy who had the video where
he just like had the gun and he was in
the warehouse and that sort of [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's the guy oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh I'm a [ __ ] tough jumper I got
my
guns [ __ ] love their guns and
shooting and overcompensating for the
things that they lack whether it's
intelligence or down there either head
it's pretty wait you mean down there
like in the front or like Donald Trump
in the back where he's trying to stuff
and get the beat I think it's I think
it's in the front but okay he's also
pretty large so he might have some
classified documents in his trunk as
well so a lot of mushroom size stuff
going on yeah yeah very small very small
heads gotcha so when I
this guy you know is insurrectionist Q
Anon believer but the reason
that and he was at he was at the oh he
was at the Youngstown Ohio rally uh this
past weekend coming up there and talking
about who he is and what he represents
all the [ __ ] but the reason that he's in
the news now is because of Stolen Valor
oh you're telling me you're telling me
that these megalodites uh have the have
went in stovallor yeah I I now I
remember this now I remember this so he
the reason it became a big thing is
because the RNC was helping it was like
900 000 or so dollars that they were
pushing into yeah almost a million bucks
right yeah into the because they really
thought they could get him to win yeah
they were they were funding his uh
marketing commercials everything as the
race leads up to the midterms the
problem is that when this [ __ ] came out
that oh it turns out that he lied about
missing his grandmother's funeral and
serving in Iraq he lied about his actual
time in Afghanistan he lied about
actually having this position as a
member of the military this came out in
the RNC was like oh [ __ ] and they pulled
the rug right from under him they took
it
took all the funding and they're like
dude you're on your own we cannot
support you because you lied
about where you served what you served
where you were what you did like all of
these things and again go figure that
it's a it's a trump-loving human
insurrectionist that says oh actually uh
I served in the military and I did these
things when it actually wasn't he didn't
serve where he said he was he wasn't in
Afghanistan he wasn't there he was I
think he was in Qatar uh which is
thousands of miles away yes that was the
story this morning and they they pulled
the funding here the bonehead is the
alpha cook here he is cucking himself
this is a clip from a press conference
this morning where he's trying to
explain this away and again you see his
sign back here Majewski America First
veteran for congress listened to his
Donald Trump style excuse and I think
Donald Trump should just think this and
get this out in the open listen to his
excuse hero why these lies aren't actual
lies
the inquiry States
we show one deployment to Qatar from May
2002 to November 2002.
what he did meaning me
or where he may have went from that
location we do not have visibility on
in fact the orders and the military
records that I've been able to
obtain from my personal files shows that
all of my deployments are listed as
classified
foreign
could not actually produce these
documents because when they were
questioned they said yeah he was in
Qatar and this is when he was there
but the idea that he goes well look
nobody knew where I was because they
[ __ ] secret Ops that was a [ __ ]
Navy SEAL I was the guy who killed Osama
Bin Laden [ __ ] that is this guy
right here um he's going to claimency
classified because I was working on top
secret [ __ ] dog right that is the guy
that this is this is the 100 you know
what you know what I wonder if we could
get Joe Biden to just think that these
records should be Declassified and then
bam we could fix this we could fix this
Majewski problem and get this out in the
open because they want transparency baby
that's what they want they want
transparency they want freedom they want
Liberty so Joe Biden I'm calling on the
president United States Joe Biden to
think just to have the thought that
these records that Majewski is claiming
are classified so we know the truth
about him because we all want to know
he's the Great American Patriot that he
claims to be Joe Biden please think it
that way we know it this is yeah please
declassify those military records to
prove that Majewski actually isn't this
crazy spy covert classified Soldier
that's out running Gun and shooting
killing all that [ __ ] this guy's a
[ __ ] cuck and that's why I put
him on Alpha cut this week for a Stolen
Valor for his line about serving in the
military and what he did and then you
know the the the trumpy thing that he's
doing here is digging an even deeper
hole by going out and saying this
nonsense and creating I mean he's trying
to salvage his campaign office he's like
hey you can't prove I didn't do this if
the documents don't actually exist yeah
they're classified I guarantee someone
from the Air Force is now going to come
out and be like nope we do have the
document I'm waiting for the reporter
I'm waiting for the reporter to ask Joe
Biden to declassify these things just
think it tell us out loud just say it
out loud and boom it's true I'm waiting
for a moment where he could tweet it he
could tweet it Gabe he could he could
[ __ ] tweet it I'm just saying I I
know he still got his Twitter account he
could tweet that these records are
Declassified and boom it will be done he
doesn't even have to think it he can
just tweet it tweet it tweet us and it
Beth right oh my god well the other
thing I just want to point out is like
you know
I feel kind of bad for people who have
to go through the whole like uh Stolen
Valor root routine right they're like I
served and I was a military vet or
whatever I did this or I was here and
lie about that to like feel some sort of
uh like relevance right he served in the
military why would he lie about it sir
right yeah exactly it's honorable to
serve in the military regardless of
where they assigned you to be but to lie
about those things as a as a person
running
for a seat as a politician well I mean
we see how that turns out with like
Madison Gotham we see how that turns out
yeah yeah and and even and even uh
several others like like Tom Cotton he's
he's he's participating in stolen viral
like exaggerating his military service
it's ridiculous speaking of a ridiculous
exaggerations the dishonorable mentioned
this morning is Kevin McCarthy because I
want to let you folks know that the
Republicans release their commitment to
cruelly for America this morning
um Gabe there wasn't a lot of people
watching this thing I think most the
people that were watching were people
who were going to do what we're doing
which is [ __ ] knocking on it trying
to give people how to politicize this
thing literally uh they basically the
tenements of this thing is hey we want
white Christian domestic terrorist
nationalists to not have Law and Order
everyone else brown black people
liberals we want them to have Law and
Order and we want Cops to go take after
them I mean unless the cops come after
us white Christian nationalists then
we'll beat them with flags Bulls at the
Capitol yeah but also also they want to
get rid of Education they don't want
your children to have education and the
best part is they're going to undo
everything that Joe Biden did including
infrastructure that they go out and they
get big checks to and they're bragging
about and lowering drug prices in the
inflation reduction act
um and they're bitching about high gas
prices as they go down which doesn't
make sense
I really I don't think that Kevin
McCarthy
is doing himself much good even if Newt
Gingrich tweets about how this is the
con new contract for America when it's
not even resembling close to the
contract for America it's only cruelty
on Americans they want they want America
where they have the leg up where they
there's no equality there's no equity
it's only a nation for white Christian
nationalists and the domestic manga
terrorists right that they are and
remember what happened this week
specifically talking about those
domestic terrorists from January 6th
they had the people the 1776 restoration
movement flooded the uh the VA suicide
hotline
so to demand that they release the
January 6 protesters like this is the
this is these are the people that say oh
Patriots [ __ ] serve and we're in the
military and all this [ __ ] like
they want to flood the line that is a
resource to to Veterans who are who are
dealing with suicide or thoughts of
suicide and flood them so those people
can't get the resources because they
want a [ __ ] [ __ ] and moan about how
some person that stormed the capital and
broke the law and threatened to hang the
vice president is now serving time or is
in is in uh jail waiting for their court
appearance this is the same group of
people that want to do this to the
people that we so
gratefully thank and say thank you for
the service but within the same breath
we'll say you know you can go [ __ ]
yourself I don't really care about you
well here's Elite stefanik and Kevin
McCarthy throwing it around the idea
that hey if you're a domestic terrorist
we're gonna get you off the watch list
because you're one of us because they
know we know they they all see
themselves as domestic terrorists they
said at the Nazi rally down in Texas uh
at the CPAC meeting let's listen to
Elise stefanik and Kevin McCarthy say
how they're gonna get domestic
terrorists off the watch list priority
for our education Committee in the next
Congress
so I hope we
I'll make this personal pledge I don't
know that if it happened but any parent
that got put on the terrorist watch list
by the dod priority he says he goes on
to say that he's going to take them off
the watch list any domestic terrorist
who is threatening elected officials I'm
gonna make sure to get you off the watch
list because we don't want punishment
for white Christian National Domestic
terrorists we just don't want that in
this America and Trump's America we want
to make sure white people can do
whatever they want commit whatever
violence they can try to even overthrow
elections they can even try to overthrow
elections Gabe you know what you know
what they got yeah that that that uh
threatening people their lives was
totally cool under the Constitution I
didn't know that Tony I didn't know that
those that we were feltically accused
imprisoning these people that were that
were making death threats Cape it's the
white Constitution it's the one that
white people have to follow white
Christian Nationals have a different
Constitution it's a different one than
what other speaking of white people
going after and denigrating
migrants brown people as he as as just
pieces of meat we go back to the winter
Ron DeSantis here
um again there's not enough I Gabe you
could probably do a four-hour uh rant on
this oh yeah just from your experience
of being the reason why you're here in
this country is because your dad came
here really honestly almost everyone
watching here that's in America I'm here
my family came in the late 19th century
as migrants to this country yeah they
crossed over the border and this country
welcomed the migrants to this country
they worked hard they had shitty jobs
they had a sh they had they had shitty
living conditions even then because they
were broken poor but they knew Coming to
America there was opportunity for
Liberty and freedom and equality and
equity
and that's what they strive for and
that's what they were pushing for they
really truly believe that that's why all
of us are [ __ ] here in the first and
unless you have native blood and you are
native then right we stole it from you
right we still I mean like the the way
that Republicans look at this is like
they go they get invited to play a game
they take the ball and they say no one
can play the game anymore that's what
this is they got invited to play which
is oh we were migrants and we came to
this country seeking a better life right
we see the Statue of Liberty we see
these things great boom Beacon of Hope
and as soon as we get here and we make
our lives better because that is what
this country is all about
then they say ah you know what actually
we don't need any more people that don't
look like us right there's too many
you're getting to be to where you're
you're really happy to to uh like the
light-skinned area is getting a little
dark and and that is what they say when
they're unhappy with the fact that the
white representation of their caucus
whatever is actually becoming diverse
and becoming the Melting Pot that
America is and should be but they feel
threatened for whatever either the
opportunities the talent the skill the
intelligence
just the beauty of people who come that
aren't looking white right like there's
they feel threatened by just the
presence of someone who doesn't look
like them who isn't mediocre who isn't
just average they feel threatened by
these people and the immediate reaction
they have is nope no no you can't come
you can't no you can't be here because
that's not fair that's not that's not
fair that's not fair to me because
you're threatening me I mean that's what
it is really well it's cruelty it's
cruelty and it's their commitment to
Cruelty and this guy's commitment to
Cruelty because we know he's a fascist
down in Florida and he's laying out a
blueprint right for a fascist state of
America Florida you have a large
population that literally came from Cuba
right like that is the they're migrants
and then you're gonna say you know
what's funny too about these these these
Venezuelans that they they coerced on a
plane and sent to Martha's Vineyard do
you know what type of government they
were actually leaving persecution from
do you know it wasn't it wasn't a
fascist government it's the one one that
they always taught they always say what
they call us
um what do they call us this libtards
they call us kamiyu Kami coming to me
coming in communist oh yes they come
from a a communist government where
they're they're seeking Refuge from
persecution in the communist government
and they can't even they can't even
pluck their head out of their ass long
enough to figure out that oh these these
people are actually gonna be against the
Lipton the Communists here and the
reason why they're not is because that's
not how it works that's not what it is
because there's only one commitment to
cruelty in this in this country and it's
the Republican party it's Donald Trump
Ron DeSantis and Kevin McCarthy and
let's do this
let's give the winner his due here Ron
DeSantis bonehead of the week folks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] that bone end of the week that's
what I see Rhonda Sanchez [ __ ] you you
can go [ __ ] yourself speaking of that
and go to go to store.dtonymichaels.com
and get your Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ]
himself merch t-shirts hoodies coffee
mugs wear it loudly and proudly at
Rhonda Santa's can go [ __ ] himself and I
think that's a Kim so he can go [ __ ]
himself well I think that's a great a
Great Rally crime because really with
this cruelty this commitment to Cruelty
on America that the Republicans are
releasing today it's more the same it's
more the brown people aren't Real
Americans we'll ship them wherever we
want them we'll treat them as meat
they're not really they're not they're
here illegally even though they're here
legally seeking Asylum from Refuge from
a communist country it really is um it's
weird that we have to explain this to
people but folks we do have to lean into
democracy we do have to do that and how
you can do that is watch the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central on YouTube Twitter and twitch
we're back on YouTube folks and we're
back off our band so go follow the Tony
Michaels podcast and if you're on the
Midas touch Network right now watching
the replay of bone of the week subscribe
to minus touch but also go over to the
Tony Michaels podcast and download every
single episode of the podcast at Apple
Spotify Google and follow us on the
Tweety tweets and the trendy trends at
Tony Michael's pod that's where you vote
for bone end of the week every single
week you decide you vote we break it
down every single Friday on the Tony
Michaels podcast and the replay on Midas
Touch Network right here on the tubes of
you it's been a great week what a bunch
of news they really are showing their
true colors it's a lead up into this
election so lean into it engage in your
democracy if you're if you're on the
live version here stick around we have a
few announcements right after the song
thanks for joining boned of the week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]